with the rise in popularity and
influence of the souls born franchise
the gaming industry has displayed some
poor tendencies in regards to how it
discusses difficulty in games
specifically in how it relates almost
anything hard to being like Dark Souls
today I think we've kind of made the
Dark Souls of competitive first-person
shooters calling every new game their
releases with even a hint of difficulty
the new Dark Souls isn't productive for
anyone it's a lazy way of trying to
easily connect complicated ideas and it
fails because of how its employed with
little to no nuance as the title implies
I wanted to discuss the problem with the
recent trend of calling a game like Dark
Souls which consists of a plethora of
games that journalists and reviewers
have unprofessionally related to Dark
Souls
via very thin examples such as solely
through difficulty I also want to bring
up what I view as a more productive way
of comparing games to the souls series
as you saw in the opening clip that the
like Dark Souls trend is very weak
comparisons of current flavor of the
month games to Dark Souls because the
game is harder than most modern triple-a
titles games like Crash Bandicoot are
not done any benefit by being related to
Dark Souls in review almost everything
about the games are so different that a
comparison without extremely heavy
conditionals and clarifications fails to
properly connect the idea that is meant
to be a link between the games and this
doesn't help the player get a better
idea of what the game is like and
whether or not they want to purchase it
a game like cuphead is varied a service
by being called anything like the Dark
Souls of 2d shooters or the Dark Souls
of platforming no core feature of souls
is present in cuphead except maybe a
focus on boss fights but if that's the
bar of comparison here then we're really
out of luck because I can guarantee the
Dark Souls did not begin or define such
gameplay focus and there are many many
games that came before the soul series
that serve as clear and direct
inspiration for the gameplay in cuphead
games like contra or Megaman are a lot
more similar to cut that and you can see
direct influences in gameplay
a comparison to these games would do so
much more to quickly let a player know
what type of game cuphead is it's clear
that most games that get the like Dark
Souls treatment don't share many or any
core features with the souls born
franchise it generally boils down to the
idea that if a game is difficult it must
be like Dark Souls since Dark Souls is a
and apparently the only difficult game
in this vein a polygon article described
cuphead as quote not the Dark Souls of
2d shooters quote because the game
wasn't hard enough that's what draws the
line
cuphead isn't like Dark Souls because it
isn't as hard as Dark Souls not because
it's a wildly different gaming graphics
soundtrack gameplay feel length tone or
anything else not because it's a game
very very similar to the games like Mega
Man and contra and play style and design
the actual differentiating factor is
that it just isn't as hard if you
couldn't tell by now I find it pretty
ludicrous that Dark Souls has been
reduced to just heart this also
negatively affects the soul series
because people who haven't played it or
don't know about it will come to know it
as only the one thing that reviewers and
journalists reference it with regards to
that it's hard
I'm actually really happy I've already
played a good amount of souls because I
wouldn't know what to think of it with
all these shoddy comparisons plenty of
games are hard a huge chunk of games
made before the year 2000 are at least
as hard as Dark Souls if not more so
using Dark Souls as an interchangeable
term for difficulty hurts both the soul
series and the game that's being
compared I get that it's a quick way to
relate an idea about a game but it
should be used to provoke many ideas
about a game as the core Souls
experience is a lot more than just
difficulty a better way that comparisons
could be drawn is in reference to games
that actually do heavily rely and try to
build off of souls like elements there
are quite a few souls like games that
share many attributes with souls as
opposed to games which are labeled like
souls by journalists there's almost a
sub-genre of Dark Souls clones that are
popping up which seek to use Dark Souls
core formula and bring about new
interesting games with it
Lords of the fall in the surge neo dark
mouse even hollow knight to an extent
all of these games are varying degrees
of an intimate connection with the Dark
Souls formula
could not be fully reviewed explained or
analyzed without at least mentioning
Dark Souls all of these games are much
better examples of games that should
have a Dark Souls comparison in their
reviews if any game should and it
definitely does seem the case that these
games do receive such comparisons which
is good games like neo and the Serge
directly draw on the souls experience in
the majority of gameplay instances and
try succeeding or not to make a new game
out of these games like Halle Knight are
great instances of muddying the line
that I just drew drawing on tools like
elements but implementing a large amount
of very different features and gameplay
mechanics that really attest to the
game's uniqueness at least when it comes
to being a Souls clone I'm not trying to
say that any game which isn't a Dark
Souls clone cannot be compared to souls
I'm just trying to get us to do away
with the overabundance of shoddy souls
comparisons in games that really don't
have many similar characteristics at all
it hurts both parties in those cases but
such comparisons can really benefit
analysis of games that are clearly
putting some or many souls elements to
work
we even need to stop being so lazy as to
try and relate any idea of difficulty as
a synonym for Dark Souls or get smarter
and what we recognize Souls and its
influence as and apply comparisons to
such only when they are really there
looks like a light drizzle on Saturday
but all gone by Sunday meaning just a
few scattered clouds to pepper your
Sunday looks like it's gonna be the dark
sauce up weather